the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media I want to say thank you
thank you for watching this show thank
you for supporting this show and thank
you for supporting my special go check
it out it's all my YouTube It's called
Lefty son it's something I directed
produced did all of it and I'm very
proud of it all right so check that out
share it with some friends
um and then come see me on tour all new
material coming on tour uh starting in
Fort Wayne Indiana May 26th and 27th
I'll be in Tacoma Washington on June
23rd and 24th in Appleton Wisconsin July
7th and the 8th uh yeah that's Indy 500
weekend so for the 14 people that are
going to be left in Fort Wayne come on
out and see your boy uh and if you gotta
have more then you gotta check out the
patreon it's called the Honeydew with
y'all it's five bucks a month is no
tears and levels and [__] like that it's
just the Honeydew with y'all and y'all
have the craziest [__] stories out
there check it out it's worth a month of
it I promise you you sign up for a year
you're getting over a month free all
right you're also getting the Honeydew a
day early you're getting it ad free
you're getting the audio and the video
separately if you want it at no
additional costs all right now that's
the biz you guys know what we're doing
over here we're highlighting the low
lights and I'm very excited to have this
guest back on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Anthony Ferraro
welcome back to the Honeydew it what's
going on it's a pleasure to have you
back young man's good to hear your voice
in person that's
nice to you to say thank you
until you're the only guy I could tell
how good looking I am yeah good luck I'm
telling you don't listen to what anybody
says you're a great looking black man
you thought I was a black guy I said you
know I've gotten that a lot and that's
how Tom segur and I met and Tom Segura
has sight
[Laughter]
you should see I got nice I'm an
Italian-American I got a nice olive skin
I don't have that white [__] yeah
I've been told I have darker skin in the
summertime yeah and I get pasty I look
nicer with a little you know sun kissed
on my face
um all right before we get into
um everything we're gonna talk about
today please plug promote everything
yeah I got um everything's on
asfvision.com ASF Vision across the
board for social medias I got my uh
document or the four bad eyes podcast
with Dan mancina Everywhere You Stream
podcasts and then uh my wrestling
documentary even if you don't know
wrestling it's a great film to watch
because it's a lot more than that it's
about like overcoming obstacles and
pushing through adversity it's called a
shot in the dark on Amazon Prime video
title yeah Vimeo uh and Apple TV and
Google Play
now you were telling me outside that
your brother and someone else who else
was it this did a documentary about that
did actually produce this yeah so this
guy uh my brother made a little teaser
about me talking about what it's like to
be a blind wrestler wrestling like
sighted kids and dealing with like I
used to you all call us yeah you [__]
able-bodied pieces of [__] sorry
demonetizing already
people used to say like because when I
wrestled you start from the line you
know in the middle and I would have to
start it's two-hand touch so my hands
would be touching yours and then the
second referee blows whistle we start
wrestling you have to stay in contact
and the second we break away they gotta
uh blow the whistle so no one gets hurt
okay and brings back to the center so
people would say I had an unfair
advantage or that I was faking my
blindness to uh get an unfair advantage
in wrestling this is it's actually this
I don't mean to interrupt you but this
is what I call it's actually it's an
unfair disadvantage you don't have sight
it's like those guys with those [__]
legs in the Olympics that are like the
spring legs and they're hauling ass pass
everybody they're like that's an unfair
advantage of like so like you have
nowhere disadvantage
it's an unfair disadvantage that's what
I'm saying I remember one time someone
was saying to my dad like you know it's
messed up you're having your kid fake
blindness to get a unfair advantage and
at the time when he was doing that I was
tripping over the bleachers having no
idea where I was
the first time it happened was my eighth
so seventh grade is my first year
wrestling and I was awful like I was
like I'm gonna go out there and beat
everyone I went two and twelve and one
of the wins was a forfeit where you just
get your hand raised yeah it didn't make
weight yeah yeah
and then I like started training every
day at a club four nights a week going
to tournaments every weekend and uh
eighth grade I end up going undefeated
and in the track are you wrestling
sighted kids yes able bodies able bodies
and you're 8-0 in that [__] oh
24-0
yeah and then I was doing really well
and then the last match the last
tournament weight class 160 my whole
life still fighting 160. are you really
yeah
um so I was losing 13 nothing
and the the kid uh we're on our feet and
my dad's like don't give up you know you
gotta throw him I threw him to his back
and pinned him everyone goes crazy and
the dad will look at the lateral drop
yeah exactly that's exactly right he was
leaning that's the grandson
you're right about I pulled the kid
inside
yeah and freaking prayed that that
reflection
I'm not even happy I'm relieved exactly
I didn't even like jump up I was like
that really happened
and the kids shook my hand no problem
the dad came over to my dad was like
your son has an unfair advantage in this
sport it's not fair to my kid he needs
to go in the Special Olympics what's the
unfair advantage that I have to stay in
contact he's like it throws my kid's
game off and then my dad's like get out
of here this kid just worked his ass off
like you know whatever and my brother
saw me dealing with all this stuff like
in high school because he was a great
wrestler I forget I apologize were you
born blind or or did you lose your sight
at a certain age no I was born with a
degenerative eye condition and it was
sort of like it was still terrible sight
but I used to be able to see like
pretty decent for me and then seventh
grade junior year of high school and
like a couple years ago lost like huge
chunks you just wake up and you're like
ah [__] and you know I'm not seeing it
today
and uh yeah so that was brutal but you
just life keeps going all right so your
brother I'm sorry your brother's seeing
you deal with all this stuff yeah and he
took fifth in the state of New Jersey
for wrestling so he was really good and
uh he was like dude it's just amazing
you're getting up and not letting these
people stop you and you're working your
butt off and he uh he took a teaser like
two minute trailer teaser thing of me
just talking about what it's like to be
a blind wrestler and growing up and I
was also accepted to a high school that
both my brothers went to and then when
the president died they sent a letter
saying you're no longer accepted we
don't want to have to provide any
accommodations for you or anything like
who sent this this was a high school
that I was supposed to go to
it was a private high school and they
were like you're never mind yeah they
rescinded my if that's the right word
they rescinded my uh acceptance after
the president who gave me the
handwritten letter of acceptance died
and that was the eighth grade year Jesus
yeah I'll never forget that and that was
brutal because I was like I can't go
somewhere because it's something I can't
even control with my life you know so
acceptance was wait can you read Braille
yeah that's what I read did that letter
come in Braille no well okay which is
cruel as [__] but also but here's the
thing someone else is sharing that news
with you in your life there's two people
that are being like [__] that sucks yeah
who's reading that to you my mom oh and
I'll never forget I've got a mom she was
at this school at the meeting they
wouldn't let me go to the meeting
because they didn't want me to have to
experience that my parents wanted me to
be there but the school wouldn't let me
and my mom was like crying like crazy I
went to this school in Philadelphia when
I was younger I used to go from Jersey
to Philly every day to learn it was a
School for the Blind to learn how to
read and write in Braille and all that
stuff and the principal was there it was
a Catholic school and she was their
sister Meg I'll never forget and my
mom's like crying in the meeting like
any like Mom would be you know just so
upset and my sister Meg looks at my mom
she's like and the school is called
there's Christian in the name I'm not
gonna shout out to the school but
um the sister looks at my mom she's like
Sue what are you crying for this is this
school ain't Christian and they walked
out and it was not yeah so I was like
real powerful and so there was all that
that I dealt with my brother was just
like inspired by me like just not
letting any of that stop me I talked
about what it's like to be a blind
wrestler in my junior year when I won
districts
my brother posted it saying this is my
little brother I want to make a film
about him I don't have all the resources
if you're a camera operator producer
whatever like please reach out and Chris
Sikorski who's an independent filmmaker
who was my high school teammate my High
School coaches college teammate no [__]
yeah he reached out and to my brother
and said what are you doing with this
this story is amazing my brother wanted
to make like a short film like you know
10 20 minutes and Chris and him sat down
decided to make a full feature length of
my senior year and like follow me around
everywhere uh get all this like raw
footage and put it together at the end
and people were like how is it having
all those cameras I'm like I didn't see
a thing so it didn't bother me
so that was one thing but it definitely
added some pressure because the whole
story is like trying to become the first
blind state champion this has never
happened no to this day
I mean unless you got one more injury
you do it every time I watch that film I
it gives me freaking PTSD because I lost
by a point to go to Stage it was brutal
and uh
so they just they follow me around like
thousands of hours of footage and then
after senior year it kind of got put on
the Shelf because life happened for
everyone and then two I graduated 2013.
so in 2015 Chris takes it off the shelf
he's like there's an amazing story here
I got to put it together he puts
together the first 15 minutes and the he
would calls my brother all excited
they're both pumped and the day or two
before that my brother was supposed to
meet with him and see it he didn't wake
up from his sleep at the age of 27 and
it was like what it just bad bash like
yeah he wasn't like that at all but it's
just one time could be the wrong yeah of
like I it wasn't I don't even know man
it was just
it was really tough and I remember I was
living in California at the time I came
home and to add insult to injury two
months or a couple months after that
happened I'm at my buddy's house and
someone's like you gotta go home you
gotta go home and like just pulling me
home like this voice in my head was so
loud and I get home I was like I gotta
go home they were all going out and I
made my buddy drive me home and I found
my mom at the bottom of the stairs in a
coma she had fallen down the stairs and
like hit her head and it was like a
traumatic brain injury she was in a coma
for like two months and it was like the
scariest thing ever is she okay now yeah
she's doing amazing like miraculous
recovery
um she just and that's within two months
of your brother passing away uh not two
it was August to January so it was
pretty too close enough yeah and you
know when life happens this is what you
were telling me outside like to add
insult to injury your brother dies right
before the documentary comes out doesn't
get to see it you can't [__] see it
[Music]
I think I'm realizing too and I hate to
say this but I have to because it's what
this show is all about but
your brother wanted to make a short film
if they would have gone with the
shortcut
oh man
I had to go feature like you
[__] oh man I just I never
thought about it like that I figured you
had I figured
oh man Ah that's terrible all you had to
do the [__] long one
I'm telling you I feel empty my bones I
feel like oh no dude he didn't even see
the trailer damn it God and after he
died Chris came to the funeral and like
vowed like to us and my family like no
matter what it takes I'm finishing this
oh yeah it was a great story like in his
memory for everyone and I Gotta Give a
lot of credit to Chris because he had
all these different cameras that were
taking footage the whole time and like
people helping them is all out of pocket
like funded independently and he went
through like tens of thousands of hours
of footage getting the right angles to
line things up just to make this a story
and he did an incredible job like it you
wouldn't think you're watching a
documentary it's like a movie almost and
that's great there's some really special
scenes in there where my brother
surprises me there's an interview with
my brother at the end that I don't even
know about yeah so it's like my brother
lives on forever through that film which
is great and
we raised money on Kickstarter we had to
raise money after so we had the trailer
that Chris made and like told the
backstory and we had to raise 36 000 by
the end of the month or else it all goes
back and then four days and six hours we
raised 36 Grand and then wow yeah it was
incredible like all these people coming
to bat and like just people we had no
idea who they were all over the country
and world like just giving money to the
film and wanting to see it finish and we
raised like 87K at the end of the month
[__] yeah but we actually needed that
much we were just scared to put that
yeah so it was it was amazing to see
that happen well and
then when the trailer the trailer went
viral or across like a bunch of
platforms had like a couple million
views and I'm standing at home feeling
sorry for myself
like
wrestling didn't go as planned basically
like I did really well I won like 122
matches in high school holy [__] dude
yeah and one District twice yeah it was
I like I thought I sucked at the end of
it but when I look back I'm like I
actually did pretty good you know it's
hard to see that in the moment and
that's a one-on-one sport I was just
talking to a friend about this yesterday
of all the sports I played and I played
soccer
basketball baseball football lacrosse
[__] you name it we played it and
wrestling was the one sport where if you
truly cheated yourself you you literally
paid for it you knew you knew there
wasn't a guy behind you that could pick
up the fumble or or you know missed uh
follow or follow you up on the Miss
ground ball it's just if like that the
kid you hit he was leaning yeah he was
nobody in there he could push him back
up and help him it's just him there's
only one person you could blame that's
it the referee that's it the ref it's
always there it's always the ref but uh
that was yeah so I'm sitting home like
watching all this stuff happen with the
film and I'm like damn like I want to
get back after something like a goal you
know like I need to really strive for
something because I'm feeling like very
stagnant at the moment and don't feel
like I'm moving forward I'm still
grieving my brother like always grieving
him but that that time is so fresh and
I'm staying home I get a phone call and
they're like is this Anthony Ferraro I'm
like who the hell is this and they're
like it's it's something you always
answer all right
they're like it's the United States you
got the wrong number
yeah yeah who the [__] is this
oh I'm sorry um I think I have the wrong
number
so who is it calling the United States
Olympic Committee okay and they're like
we saw your documentary if you have any
of that Talent left
you still got out
of the house
so it came out like 2018 but it was from
high school yeah I was like you're like
if you got anything left in you would
you consider training Judo to try and
compete in the Paralympics and I was
like [__] I guess this was that call I
was looking for and like when these
opportunities come in life you got to
take listen that's opportunity calling
yeah exactly you try to be like who the
[__] is this who the [__] are you so
wait you never had taken or studied Judo
before no but they're asking like hey we
got the slot we need to fill yeah well
they're trying to get so with paralympic
Judo the only disability is visual
impairment so what do you mean oh that's
the only one you're allowed to have yeah
in Judo I see yeah so it was now it's
like why why couldn't you be missing
like part of your arm I think it's just
why couldn't you I don't know man
because you can't grab you can't but you
could still get in there
look you know damn well like I do it
doesn't strength has got nothing to do
with your senses this [__] will
figure out a way to chicken wing your
neck off you know what I mean it could
be a disadvantage no this could be
another unfair disadvantage it's a great
point I don't know why they don't why
why couldn't you do Judo with just
missing a hand
that's a great question uh you would
think they would would that be
acceptable is missing a hand acceptable
for the Paralympics
what is the actual definition is it any
what do you know
they have a they have a written
definition there's all different
disabilities for different sports which
is kind of crazy okay like there's
wheelchair basketball right okay so they
kind of I don't know are you allowed to
play that I don't know that's a good
question I don't think so you're like I
don't know where the [__] I am out there
but man lock me up but I'm about three
years old today
what if you're Steph Curry from the
[__] wheelchair dude I had um you
know Marshawn Lynch yeah I was at a
event a cannabis and basketball event
okay in Arizona and I was trying to make
a layup and I had Kelly my wife tapping
on the backboard with my cane oh yeah
I've seen I've seen people do this for a
foul shot so I went up to do a layup and
I had no idea that Marshawn was trying
to block me the whole time and I jumped
on
yeah eat it and people like Marshall is
really trying to get you
you're playing this Joy let's use
somewhere on video yeah yeah
I threw a football to Gronk I've done a
few things but he was he was the whole
time he's like you ain't [__] blind
and like just messing with me and we had
a great time but and then uh uh Derek
Fisher taught me how to shoot a free
throw okay that was fun but yeah we the
Paralympics called and I just started
training like non-stop how old were you
when you started training for that 2018
so was it 23 five years ago 23. so
you're 28 now yeah and at 20 so five
years out of high school you start
training for the the Paralympics yeah
and a sport you've never never trained
okay they sent me it's all self-funded
so I had to get myself places what yeah
that's there's no money in the parallel
it's [__] the everything's
self-funded getting all these
competitions and you've got to get to
the competition what's the what's the
reward
a medal I guess so what about your cash
back I could cost fifteen thousand
dollars to get here now they're starting
yeah
but now they're starting to pay for if
you get a medal like at World
Championships and stuff they'll like pay
you a couple thousand dollars which
isn't that much
so it's really just oh myself
it's I don't know man well yeah what
actually is it see I struggle with that
thought all this because it sounds to me
like let's strip away what who's
involved and all that like let's get all
our feelings out of it it sounds like a
company based off of people funding
themselves to get to these places to do
these events so that the said big
company can get the sponsors and stuff
and make the money and they pay them
nothing and you're like the show for
them that's it yeah it's it's crazy it
sounds a lot like comedy
sounds a lot like gray parallel and uh
but they do for like people that have
placed in the Olympics before they'll
fund their Journey moving forward okay
so they're like this person's worth my
time type of thing and then you head out
on this journey do you go out and do it
dude I went to England I went to Tokyo I
went to Brazil I went to Brazil how much
money hold on before we talk about how
well you did how much money do you think
you've spent on the Paralympics
fifty thousand dollars Jesus Christ how
much you think you've got back from them
three concussions
[Laughter]
that's the greatest
[Music]
all right so how many years are you
doing this man you're making me not want
to do this anymore
you just thought you're telling me you
said you questioned her I do I do I feel
like you're asking the right questions
I don't blame you for questions I guess
it's more like staying in shape the
mental like having something to
challenge yourself because you always
got to be out of your comfort zone in
life you know and how are you doing out
there I'm doing are you whipping these
Brazil kids ass I took third place in
Brazil [__] yeah well I beat a Brazilian
while the whole [__] arena is going
Brazil Brazil I'm like shaking the [__]
I was like America
[Laughter]
who's got the best crowds who shows up
Brazil for sure they show up hard they
do huh and then like these like Central
Asian countries like I went to
Azerbaijan never even heard of it I
didn't hear of it before I went there I
had to learn how to pronounce that [__]
and like they were those people are nuts
because all they do is wrestle and do
Judo and so that the whole whole people
of yeah people doing that yeah
yeah and then uh
so I stuffed like five years of Judo in
like two years and like like 15 almost
so I got like my brown belt pretty quick
just from competitions like I won the
Black Belt division a few times in like
local cited tournaments and are you
wrestling any sighted kids during this
or uh at all not in the qualifying
tournaments so when you're doing Judo
um go ahead sorry no you're good just I
just want to know is it only site you
said the only missing site yes okay some
have deaf but they have to be blind off
I was gonna ask you that yeah
yeah
you listen I know you can't hear
but unless you can't see you can't [__]
I don't know I don't know if somebody's
translated this dude right
you ready man you ain't getting and you
sign that please
no and the crazy thing is there's people
that cheat that like countries will
cheat to get people that could actually
see in the Paralympics how do they do it
they just lie on the vision tests and
now they have like really strict like
optometrists and stuff when you go to
classify yourself I was gonna say like
these people how do they how do they act
blind how do you act blind
I don't know how do you actually you
just run into [__] uh hold on to people
I've been doing my glasses they wear
glasses and [__] yeah yeah that stuff
but like for example like a country like
I'm trying to think like maybe Ukraine
like they get treated like royalty when
they are like medalists really some of
them have gotten sports cars as rewards
in the past how the hell are you gonna
give a blind person
around
so this what do the Americans give
nothing they get a medal a metal here's
some McDonald's bucks because we're
sponsored by McDonald's
thank you for getting the sponsored free
refills for Life hey can you only wear
Nike because we're sponsored by night
mode I'm not sorry
that's what I'm saying there it is
listen to the corporations too man
listen man they didn't even like me in
the beginning because I had long hair
that's how like freaking uh like Cookie
Cutter they are too they want you to be
a certain way and they did not like me I
am I'm blind [__]
Jesus Christ it's a lot of rules in this
[__] Paralympics
oh my God all right so let's shift gears
for a second because uh congratulations
you and your wife are about to have a
baby your first baby right yeah awesome
due in August yeah um do you know if
you're having a boy or you don't have to
say no we're not finding out great I
love it did you find out yeah yeah I
thought we would but we decided not to
because you don't know if you're ever
gonna have another one so it's like why
not have the surprise it's true and I'm
gonna have a nurse yeah whisper in my
ear when the baby comes out so I can be
the one to yell it's a boy it's a girl
[Laughter]
um
I feel like a girl that's what I feel
like let's talk about this because I was
saying outside and you can ask your wife
like
sight has nothing to do with it being a
new parent is [__] terrifying oh yeah
with all your senses I can't imagine
doing it without sight so the terrifying
part is terrifying for everybody and
you're throwing in no sight on top of
this so I have a couple questions first
because I'm already having anxiety for
you but do you or can you tell if your
child is predisposed to uh blindness is
there are there tests or anything like
that are you worried about that there
are but some of them are like invasive
and I'm not worried about it if the
baby's blind is gonna have the best damn
teacher in the world no doubt that's one
thing and then second it's like why put
that fear in you the whole time and uh
oh my condition is so rare like for in
order for my baby to be blind I have
something called Libra's congenital
amaurosis and it's all genetics like so
there's there's probably thousands of
different types of genes of Libras
congenital amorosis us and within that
in order for the kid to have Libras
my Gene Kelly has to be a carrier of the
same exact Gene as my condition inside
the genes okay and my parents didn't
know they were carriers and we have
um the last of five and they all have
one to four chance of being blind and I
was the only [__] that got it
yeah
either win the lottery or be blind
there's no quick fix for anxiety and
depression it's not finding a new
therapist or starting an exercise
routine it's not more in regular
meditation or a better diet sometimes
you need something to unlock your brain
a new way of thinking about and seeing
the world and maybe that thing is guided
ketamine therapy for mind Bloom there's
a new tool to improve your mental health
at home ketamine therapy mind Bloom is
the leader in at home ketamine therapy
having safely helped thousands of people
overcome their anxiety and depression me
included unlike traditional talk therapy
ketamine Works quickly and doesn't have
the unpleasant side effects of
traditional antidepressants in a study
of over 1 200 mindbloom clients 89
reported improvements in their anxiety
and depression after only two sessions
I've gone through quite a bit in the
last six months and I can tell you that
this absolutely helped me with my
anxiety so right now mind Bloom is
offering my listeners 100 bucks off your
first six program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Honeydew and you use the
promo code honeydew take the first step
and break free from your anxiety and
depression with mind Bloom mindbloom.com
honeydew and use promo code honeydew now
let's get back to the do oh man all
right so talk to me about being a new
like what are your concerns because I
every look every forget even being a new
dad because that's a separate thing than
being a mom of course but being a new
parent is terrifying especially today
um I'm not trying to talk you out of
this like I'm trying to talk out of that
Paralympics
yeah tell me what are you going through
right now like what are your biggest
fears what how are you prepping what are
you doing so we got like all the
little thing like the uh bassinet and
the carriers and the stroller all that
stuff diapers but I'm worried like one
if it's a girl I'm worried about
changing diapers like sanitary reasons
like if I get you know poop in the wrong
spot yeah you can't see yeah like that
I'm worried about two
this is more like usually [__] on a
boy's dick
everyone else
just owes them all a little spring put
them in the sink
but that like I'm thinking I'll use the
sink man oh you should 100 use the sink
yeah don't listen do it however you do
it yeah just do it well for your child
so your child [__] loves you and
respects you and you know looks up to
you that's it just do listen listen to
nobody and everybody and then do
whatever the [__] works the best for you
that's it I did the sink they even make
those little tubs to put in the sink and
stuff yeah yeah that's what I'm thinking
clean I mean don't be putting it in
there at all raw chickens yeah
this is like more
as a parent I guess because because I've
lost a brother and you've seen like your
family go through heartbreak I'm worried
about the first time my kid has to
experience like adversity or heartbreak
because I know that like I've been
through adversity and it sucks but it
does make you stronger but watching that
happen to a you know your child is like
that's got to be rough you know like
them going through something emotionally
or mentally like I'm worried about stuff
like that it's gonna start [__] with
you a little bit but here's the good
news for you you have a mom are you
close with your mom yeah I have 60
cousins that all live in Jesus Christ my
mom's the second oldest of 13. holy [__]
a lot of babysitters so but the thing is
unfortunately here's another dis unfair
disadvantage you have your mom to talk
to about the fears of losing a child
yeah you know what I mean like you
really that's gonna shift for you in
life seeing your mom now as a parent and
a person and now she's got to raise a
son who's doesn't have sight and she
just buried a kid like man yeah they
went above and beyond like especially
with my blindness they made sure I had
the right tools and like I'm forever
grateful for that I remember being in a
store my mom would be like I'd be like
five years old can I get this toy like
here's five bucks go find the counter
and pay for it
I don't want this toy anymore
so are you just was it just the two of
you you and your brother no so I'm one
of five so I have two older brothers two
older sisters and uh
yeah we all grew up together in the same
house my dad's like my best friend in
the whole world
um so you know my dad's like your mom
was tough it was up for me I'd be
coddling you everywhere uh holding your
hand through life but I'm thankful that
you know they let me make my mistakes
and go out and like be independent like
I used to I grew up like skateboarding
surfing and then I used to ride bikes
until I started hitting parked cars my
mom was like yeah
that day I went
people used to call my mom like
Anthony's out on a bike
he's out here wrecking bikes okay
oh man I can't believe I'm having a baby
we only had sex one time
what no I'm just kidding oh my god dude
don't [__] say that I was like you're
a mirror that's a miracle baby no I'm
joking but it's crazy like how because
some people they say it takes years you
know of trying or like yeah yeah it
happened quick good after trying so good
because yeah it could take people some
people can't they have to have help with
it you know it could take a while yeah
um all right what uh what are the fears
you said you you worried about your your
child's first time dealing with
adversity what else
um like well is your dad still alive
yeah and and so you've got him as a
person to talk to as a father for advice
as well so that's really good for you
yeah okay and I'm glad that we both
Kelly and I both work from home so we
will be able to be around the kid like
all the time which I think is important
like a lot of people going you know
after like three four months they're
back to work and there's a babysitter
now and you're spending like valuable
like key moments away from your kid so
I'm happy with that I'm scared like
because once they start walking they
start like trying to run away from you
and [__] dude that's why it changes I'm
putting ankle bracelets changes dude it
does as soon as they can walk and I'm
telling you there's something I don't
know what it is genetically weird about
toddlers but they weren't they can run
like a [__] yeah but their legs
are all weird and [__] like they
shouldn't scientifically it looks like
they shouldn't be able to run like that
but they can haul ass and you're like oh
and when you get my age and you have a
kid like everything's tight you can't
just I can't just break out into a full
Sprint anymore right away I gotta
stretch for 30 [__] minutes
yeah yeah damn yeah so that like
just
it doesn't bother me so much but I know
there's going to be people's opinions
about like oh he's blind and had a baby
like that's messed up really yeah you've
dealt with that kind of uh yeah like on
the internet like some people be like
also like it's they could be like it's
uh irresponsible to have a kid if he
could like they could have your disease
so it's like
I don't know things like that kind of
bother me I didn't know you were getting
that kind of hate not much which I'm
grateful for because I get hate every
day on the internet for what people say
I'm not blind why because they think I'm
just using it to get followers
I'm like I'll trade you all my followers
right now for your two good eyes yeah
it's crazy people always trying to like
you know break down and I'm not blind
they're like well he looked at the
camera I'm like yeah cause my wife's
yelling at me where the camera is
I also know where sound is yeah
[__]
um
but what else the the diaper changing
definitely just that's one me and Dan so
Dan's a blind dad and he taught me we
did a video together to promo the
podcast we do like little tick tocks and
stuff like that reels and he had me
changing this we got a baby doll that he
could feed the food to and it poops it
out for real yeah it's like this little
thing and
well he was showing me how to change
diaper and he was in the video he was
like laying on the bed while I was
changing the diaper with a mouthful of
water spitting it in my face and so I
get ready for the pee in the face yeah
yeah
that was funny you're not even gonna see
it coming dude you won't even see it
coming
and then like another thing is like
since I'm blind like I kind of move
I moved fast for a blind person and
sometimes it's to my like fault like
it's to my demise you know I'll be
running through my apartment and a door
will be half open and I just smack that
thing with my head so I'm worried like I
need to really slow down when I have the
kid so I can make sure the baby's safe
when I'm carrying them all right do you
um do you use your cane around your home
or are you fully used to your home or
you don't need it fully use to myself
except for [__] like that where a door
might be halfway open yeah yeah but I'm
constantly like you know I'm a train
wreck I'll like bump into [__] all the
time my shins have permanent dents in
them from like just running into stuff
um is there anywhere else you are
comfortable not using your cane outside
of your home like my parents house but
my mom's always moving [__] around yeah
so that's another one uh just like
places I frequent often like if we're
just hanging out but not like grocery
stores or anywhere like in the public
and especially like I used to live in
New York with Kelly and I I was so
anti-cane
like I wouldn't use it because I was
afraid how people looked at you and how
people will talk to you slower and
louder and do they really yeah it's
insane I'm like I'm not deaf it's
actually here yeah
and I'm like oh really like it's so it's
so demeaning like it's just it's like
really you gotta talk to me like that
and
so I was living in New York and I
wouldn't use my cane and Kelly used to
be like like the first time we ever met
we went to the outlets and I'm walking
around trying to be cool guy like not
using a cane and I'm walking with my
feet using my feet to feel we're in the
Timberland store I'll never forget that
she's like you need help and I'm like no
I got this two minutes later I run
straight into the pole in the middle of
the store and she grabs me she's like
get over here
oh
so things like that it just freaking I I
send it way too fast a lot and then in
the city I kept shoulder checking people
and people be like what the [__] is
wrong with you and like get all pissed
off so then I started using the cane and
it started pardon people like the Red
Sea right yeah if people get out of your
way or they look out for you more like
when I lived there I used to have like
you know my homeless friends that would
walk me down the street yeah we used to
get all get along it was just I used to
have guys read me the menu at the food
trucks like it was it's great that's
nice so that opened a whole new world of
freedom and Independence my mom's a
freaking orientation Mobility instructor
which is like teaching kids how to use
the cane so I always tried to like the
Bell wait did that come after okay what
are the [__] I know I know so after
you uh were born blind she took up this
occupation yeah she went back to school
and got her mask damn
um she actually got gifted like
scholarship because we're in this huge
court case because
they wanted the public school in New
Jersey wanted me to go there but they
were only going to give me like two
hours of Braille training a week which
was like you're learning print every day
so it just wasn't enough and my mom
researched and found the best school in
Philly and they sent me there but the
the state didn't want to provide any
transportation and they said it you
don't need that training like this is
plenty type of thing which sets you up
to fail in the future and then all these
people from like different organizations
came to like fight for me wow and the
Pennsylvania College of Optometry gifted
my mom a scholarship to get her Masters
after that [__] it that was awesome so
she learned a lot and then my sister
became an optometrist
no [__] yeah right so that was pretty
cool
one thing I'm worried about I actually
am a little worried like not worried but
if the kid is blind like I know what
I've gone through being blind and like
the depression and stuff like that would
suck but at least having a good role
model raising it yeah right so all right
let me ask you some questions and you
tell me how you deal with it all right
let's talk about buckling the baby in
the car seat you show me once I got that
down you can do that all the clicks and
make sure it's in there
first one time well they go backwards at
first oh [__] they're rear facing first
right yeah and then you gotta switch
them around they get big enough then
eventually they're big enough and you're
like buckle your own [__] seat
belt man you know the smell good there
that's the thing I'm gonna teach this
kid to do a lot like that's that's what
I want to ask are you going to teach
them to be as independent as possible oh
yeah I'm gonna teach them how to hold a
camera and edit too yeah put them to
work
no but thankfully like my partner is
incredible like Kelly yeah she's amazing
and I just know she's gonna be the best
mom and I can learn from her too and
she's really good at
find like something I've never done
before and then showing me a method to
do it like she's really good with that
and then she'll make things accessible
like
I'm curious to see how like what baby
things we're gonna make accessible
because like in in our home like she'll
put dot like these bump dots on the
washing machine so I know where
everything is like the buttons because
it's touch screen and then like the
spices in the kitchen like that type of
stuff so she's really thoughtful in
putting herself in my shoes
we even went to like a dining in the
dark you're trying to say she's pretty
cool for a sighty yeah
listen man I could never marry a blind
person I'd be screwed me
without the window dude
I always tried to get an Uber driver job
but it never worked what about
um when how off when do you think you'll
feel comfortable enough to stay at home
with the baby for and and for how long
that's a good question I've thought
about this too like
I don't know if we're gonna so she's
gonna breastfeed but I don't know if
we're gonna do like the bottles too if
we have the bottles that'll be helpful
but I'm scared because
when the baby cries I'll start like
freaking out like I don't know what the
baby's crying for but I guess you just
learn those things as it goes you're
gonna learn what the difference between
hunger and pain and all those things are
for sure and that like so maybe like
but no offense just looking at your baby
also it doesn't mean you got the answer
either for that you know what I mean I
wear it like not worry I am bummed I'm
not gonna be able to see like the baby
smile and like when it laughs like the
little faces it makes and stuff like
that's kind of a bummer but I'm sure
that because like when you raise your
kid that's all they know at that time so
like they're gonna be used to having a
blind dad like that's the other thing
I'm waiting for the day that my kid
comes home and be like Daddy how come no
other daddies are blind yeah oh my gosh
[__] we gotta but you can have that
conversation also because your dad
wasn't yeah you know what I mean but you
don't understand like mine wasn't so I'm
I'm the one blazing the [__] trailers
yeah yeah exactly and uh just making it
normal like I feel like the kid will
learn like that
you know Dad can't see a wave you gotta
hug him or something like that
um yeah
so like more like contact
so I'm really excited to wear like the
baby carrier so I could always have the
baby against you yeah things like that
you should be able to just tilt your
head down and kiss the top of your head
exactly that's where you see them and my
buddy like my one blind buddy Nick he
uses like bells on his daughter's feet
like in a bracelet so I'm definitely
gonna use stuff like that smart and I'm
wondering like when I'm home alone
I don't know man like it just scares me
but I'm thinking it's gonna have to be
like when we train Delta my dog like 10
minutes at a time when you leave them so
like Kelly go leave for 10 minutes and
I'll see if I can do this you know like
all right and then kind of taking
increments so that's a big thing
it's scary it's terrifying it's
terrifying it's exciting this is what
I'm saying this is what I love about
this show I'm it's such a perspective
check because I'm a parent uh I have
sight now I've lost my smell I'm still
not with without 90 of my smell since
December of 2020 and there have been
times where the smoke detector went off
I couldn't smell smoke
um there was an alert they hit our
phones like uh um
Amber Alert that said there was a
natural gas leak in the neighborhood and
people had to get out I couldn't smell
it I couldn't smell the
um uh heaters in the house nothing and I
was like holy [__] this is actually
[__] dangerous not to have and then
here you are coming into here talking
about parenting without sight and that's
where I'm like Ryan shut the [__] up bro
shut up with your little smell [__] yeah
if you took my spell I don't know what
I'd do though I'd be screwed well you
definitely could get a different [__]
um sport in the paralympicious
for this one
we have to sign you up
oh man
um okay here's another question how do
you
I don't want to use the word train at
all but how do you teach is the word
um someone who has sight to live with
someone who doesn't like what are the
things you've had to teach Kelly and
that you know you're gonna have to teach
your child
um Kelly like learns as we go she like
is a forward thinker so she's kind of
always thinking ahead like I kept
running into my we have a bed frame and
the edge is pretty sharp I kept running
into it cutting my shin and she taped a
pillow to it so I wouldn't start keep
doing that so it's more like a learn as
you go but I think the kid will learn
like just because it's that's its life
like learning like just knowing the
dad's blind that he can't see but then
I'm worried the kid's gonna think
everyone else can't see and start
streaming people like that too that's
interesting yeah yeah but like dance kid
for example he's really thoughtful about
different things like helping his dad
around if he needs it
um so I'm just
I'm gonna have to teach a lot through
like feel like showing like if I'm
trying to teach my kid how to like
shoot a basketball or something that's
one thing I hate that I can't play catch
with my kid you know what I mean I was
gonna ask you about sports yeah
I mean you you could play yeah it's
gonna hurt
but you can play because when I was
younger I used to even have enough sight
to where if you threw a football up high
enough I could see it in the sky like
that you could make out the shape yeah
like try and cats yeah but
it's going to be interesting like my
kid's gonna know uh balls with bells in
it and stuff yeah you know things like
that like I'm definitely not gonna let
it stop me from doing that stuff but
also like I'm gonna teach my kids so
many other things that like they might
not even worry about playing catch with
me and stuff that was my next question
is what are the things you're you were
those are your worries what are you
excited what about Escape team like
skateboarding uh music because I play
guitar and sing like professionally and
doing stuff like that like I jam with my
dad and that's like a really cool
bonding experience that we have
um I'm worried I mean I'm bummed I can't
take my kid for a drive like because I
remember
make sure he's in that busy
oh man yeah I hear you on that that does
I because I spent a lot of time with my
dad in the car and that was where a lot
of like conversations yeah yeah for sure
like that music you learn about music
yes listen to that
do you think you'll ever just go sit in
the car and just be like listen to this
and listen yeah I'm sure well now you
got like The Echoes and stuff too so I'd
play that
um I've been
I don't know I just I'm really gonna
bring this baby like try and mold it to
our lifestyle because we travel so much
I know people are like good luck but
like I'm really gonna try just if you
raise him that's all it knows then it
should be all right I mean there's gonna
it will be fine yeah yeah of course but
that's the other thing like scheduleism
I know I'm not gonna be able to
train and then lay down all that like
you know like have really hard workout
sessions and then just kind of lay
around I'm gonna have to be dad mode so
like changing my life like that like I
said the dumbest I've said the dumbest
things during these pregnancy this
pregnancy like Kelly will be like Oh I'm
feeling so fat and I'll be like yeah I
know me too and she's like can you shut
the [__] up for nine months and I I
don't know what maybe say this I
regretted it right after I said it but I
was going through like one of those
Panic modes like my life's about to
change like we were in Italy and we were
like having dinner and just like date
nights and stuff and I looked at I was
like you better not be one of these moms
that puts the baby first I just looked
at me like I don't know what made me say
that I don't fear fear exactly I'm like
I still need to be first in your life
but uh just things like that uh it's
freaking it's a what I felt so I felt
every single emotion through this
pregnancy like fear excitement
almost regret but like not you know like
[__] what did I do I mean I can
understand having Kelly as your partner
who helps you through everything who now
has to help take care of a baby and you
feeling like I'm gonna be neglected or
yeah looked after less or taken care of
less and and I'm here to tell you that's
definitely gonna happen yeah no doubt it
has to happen yeah yeah and the other
thing is like we do everything together
with the social media content sheet and
the podcasting she like films edits
produces everything damn she and has a
full-time job after that like doing web
development higher it's time to hire
that's the thing I'm hoping that things
can take care of themselves where we
could hire someone else too to there's
an old saying with babies comes money so
yeah yeah I'm hoping more like people
see him having a kid so they'll like
hire me for more stuff too because I do
a motivational speaking is like my main
money gig and
been trying to just stack up as many
jobs as I can before the baby comes and
just getting ready
um it sucks when you do your taxes
you're like I had that much money that I
spent you know like I shouldn't have
spent that much and then but you're like
you have to reinvest all back in your
business that's it yeah so everything we
make basically goes right back in and
I'm nervous about how that's gonna look
like with trusting someone else to do
certain things you know kind of give it
because it's your baby like the stuff
you've created well you got two of them
yeah literal one and yeah listen look
you get it as a person yeah as a person
with sight who is a [__] control
freak when it comes to my [__] too man
it's not easy to let go and Trust other
people yeah and unfortunately you are
going to go through growing pains with
that too because you're going to find
people who are they don't have your work
ethic they don't have your hustle they
don't care as much because not
necessarily theirs and they need to be
told every little detail you want
someone especially too in your life you
need a proactive person who is like
already did this I did this this is
handled this is done this is checked off
we got this still dealing with this
waiting on a call back from the thank
you exactly exactly that's exactly it
and I
just have to trust that it's gonna be
all right you know put put Faith in it
and I just I pray a lot so I'm like you
know put it all up there too and
just I know everything you don't get
in life
I really truly believe this that you
don't get anything handed to you that
you can't handle
like no matter the situation there's
people that have been through the
craziest stuff but they get through on
the other side
you know what I mean
it's
I'm having anxiety
but yeah
I know but and Cali's so proactive about
all that stuff like we do everything
like from you know seed to sale like
it's just all
the emails the getting jobs the Outreach
the marketing the everything so
just trying to hope that it's still good
like I could trust her with a camera
with a phone that she's getting the
right angles and that you know she can
because she has all the visuals actually
I get the right angle to breastfeed the
baby somebody else has got to shoot that
guy I know and then I'm gonna be like I
can't film right now because the baby's
crying stuff like that and it's just
gonna be a whole learning experience on
top of everything else you'll handle it
yeah you'll handle it I know I will it's
just it's change you know change is
always I say it all the time it's a pain
in the ass but honestly it's the best
[__] thing for you yeah it always
makes things better I truly believe that
and I think like
it gives like the second she got
pregnant I felt like I was a dad already
and I I started thinking differently I
started feeling differently about things
and it gives you a whole nother reason
to live and not let your [__] be so
loud yeah like your little depressions
and things like exactly I felt like my
depressions like things that would keep
me down like none of that [__] matters
anymore and it's really powerful too
because I'm like
it's not that bad like I'm about to have
a kid that I have to keep alive and take
care of and love and and teach right
from wrong and different things like
that so there's there's way too much
stuff my I remember my dad looked at me
he's like one day I was a little bummed
out like depressed he's like Anthony you
don't have time to be depressed anymore
you better pick this up you know that's
what I wanted to ask you are there
things you've already asked your dad
about just like I used to cry to my dad
in college that I was like I don't know
if anyone's ever gonna love me
um like because I'm blind no one I'll
never be able to have a family no one
will ever want to have a kid with me
like that was some of my biggest fears
in life because when I was in high
school and he's like son yeah you're a
fetish
let me show you this website over here
he's like type this in Google
oh dude
oh man that's great
[Laughter]
the crazy thing is Kelly had love
tattooed in Braille no on her wrist
seven years before we ever met how about
that and she didn't know any blind
people yeah yeah that was crazy but
because when I was in high school I had
a girlfriend that was like very serious
with and I was in love you know you
think it's like you think you're gonna
marry this person whatever whichever one
kind of feels in their first real love
and I'll never forget we broke up
because her parents were like he's never
gonna be able to drive you around he's
not gonna be able to take care of you
he's not gonna be able to do this and
that messed up my psyche like so bad
like my confidence and self-worth and
self-esteem all that stuff like I just
felt like who could ever love me then
so that was a tough one
and now look at you yeah I'm I can't
believe it it's you know like things
have
grown past my wildest like imagination
and like what I ever thought like I used
to be on uh Social Security and I used
to take that as like you know I'm I'm
not because they set you up to fail it's
like you can't have a certain amount of
money in your bank account you can't
have an income all this stuff and the
day I was able to say like get out of my
life to them it was the most like
freeing growing independent experience
like I felt like I finally made it you
know like but there's so many other
struggles that come with that but I'll
gladly take those to be independent from
that stuff
go for you dude I'm happy for you man
thank you uh this is a great episode and
you're gonna be a great dad you are you
know you can the fact that you care
already and that you're already worried
about it is a step ahead of most people
yeah it really is so good for you dude
um please plug and promote everything
you'd like again yeah uh asfvision.com
you can find everything on there like
the link to the documentary uh shot in
the dark and then also like the four bad
eyes podcast please go listen to that
we're trying to grow it and
um file Kelly a Keller for 24 on
Instagram too she does all the edits and
everything you see me doing so and reach
out if you want us to come try anything
in life we I'm trying to go Skydive and
do anything all right yeah I'll do
anything once
all right brother well thank you very
much so much and uh thank you guys out
there as well please go watch the
special Lefty son come see me on the
road tickets available at
ryansickler.com and as always Ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
foreign